you know if doctor who is gonna keep
having the power of love save the day
maybe they should just go ahead and
append friendship as magic on the end of
the title
and be done with it
[Music]
the lie of the land
first off that's a great title
that's a clever double meaning that's a
decent pun
i like it i am often one to groan at
puns but no
props i like that one so
this honestly i feel like the entire
thing where the fandom kind of craps on
the monk trilogy
which again to recap would be extremists
pyramid at the end of the world in this
extremist is great
pyramid at the end of the world is a
really solid setup
this thing dropping the ball seems to be
what gets people to write all three off
which is
really unfair because this is the only
one that isn't very good out of the
three
then again it is the last one and
as we learn from game of thrones when
you end
really weak people tend to not look back
on the entire thing as fondly as maybe
they would have
otherwise and i suppose that's kind of
what we've got going on
here here was the odd thing going back
and re-watching it
because i haven't watched this one in
ages
it starts really good
it's got a really really strong
opening between the washed out color
palette
zeroing in on bill as she kind of
explains
we find out sort of narrating to her
mother about
what has gone on this idea that the
monks have basically
gaslit the entire planet and
this is stuff that i didn't appreciate
that at the time that it aired but
definitely watching it now
catching the authenticity
of the propaganda machine
that the monks have put into place the
statues
the need for conformity the insistence
that they've always been here and this
is just the way the world
is i think that i mean like the statues
we find out there's more of a reason for
them anyway but like
these are the signifiers of
totalitarianism
this is how fascists operate
this is how anybody who wants
pure authority has to do they have to
stifle free thinking put a clamp down
on anyone who is going to counter their
narrative
and constantly remind their populists
of the narrative that they want them to
believe and to adhere to and the monks
check off
every single one of those boxes in the
first 20 minutes or so
and i really do appreciate the thought
that went into this idea
of the propaganda machine and
insisting on their own historical
relevance
which is another thing that totalitarian
leaning movements
if not individuals have a tendency to do
insist
on the past and the history and their
glory being somehow eternal
again really good catch really good
integration of that idea and nardole has
a line
that i love however bad a situation is
if people think that's how it's always
been
they put up with it it's 90 of the job
done
that one sentence cuts right to the
nature of human complacency
brilliantly this thing opens really
strong
and then starts falling apart once we
get the doctor back
into the story i would say that it falls
apart
on the regeneration fake out which is
completely unnecessary and
just really feels pointle like did
anybody think
that he was actually going to regenerate
with what four episodes to go left
in the series yeah nobody believes that
so there's no tension in that entire
thing
and it's it's a very silly fake out and
raises a whole
bunch of logistical questions which i'm
not going to dwell on because they don't
bother me that much but if you're the
kind of person that they do
bother the idea that the doctor can fake
a regeneration
brings up a whole ton of questions of
wait
how um so if that's something that's
going to get stuck in your craw yeah
that's an issue not one for me but it's
still kind of dumb
the thing is though it starts falling
apart even before that
and that is unfortunately the fault of
the script because the script starts
wavering too much it starts juggling too
many
things and it is a shame because
capaldi and pearl mackie
really go out of their way and do a
pretty admirable job of trying to
sell this conversation and the idea that
the doctor
actually sided with the monks which
again
i never believed for an instant
but capaldi did a really good job of
selling those words
and pro-mackey did a really good job of
performing
what i would expect to see from bill if
she did
believe him when he said that stuff
now like i said i never believed
the doctor but i believed that she
believed him
but even that taken into account
i don't buy that she shoots him that
doesn't
track for me at all
even you know upset
and agitated and on edge and like having
been
clamped down on by the monks for six
months prior to this even with all that
tension
it doesn't it does not make
sense to me for who she is as a person
that she would decide the solution is to
shoot
the doctor i don't
buy it and it becomes even stupider
when you realize the doctor wanted her
to try and shoot him not a great plan
that's needlessly
cruel and i know he tries to justify
like i had to test you and be sure you
weren't like a plant from the monks or
whatever it's a really thin
justification for putting
her completely needlessly through an
emotional ringer
to get her to take an action that
doesn't make sense for her character and
the doctor to act like
that's what i wanted you to do how
stupid you think i am
whole thing just sort of it's like a
souffle deflating at that point
so yeah it and then the tone gets really
weird because it gets weird and
light and jokey and like the doc there's
like this gag bit
about how the doctor had all of the
soldiers replaced their
cut their um their bullets with blanks
but there was one soldier who hadn't
which means if
bill had picked that soldier to take his
gun she could have actually killed the
doctor and it's played off like a joke
i'm like
what is going on we were in what is
effectively a complete
fascist state five minutes ago
is going on with this tone now
and then things after that it just keeps
adding on stuff that
it doesn't flow from one to the next
it feels very jerky and disjointed
because
from there we go to the reveal of missy
in the vault now couple things about
this
thing number one
i think it was a good idea to reveal
that missy is in the vault
at about this point in the series
one of the things i appreciate about
series 10 is even though it did the
mystery box
story series arc that i'm beyond sick of
revealing what was in the vault with
four episodes left to go
after this that's a nice relief
for me because it it takes this
stupid template that i'm really sick of
for series arcs
off the table so that i'm more going ooh
now i don't
know what the rest of the series is
going to be because i was expecting the
finale to be
what's in the vault and now it's already
been revealed
so i like that and the scene is even
good because i mean
michelle gomez michelle gomez on her own
is great and her playing off capaldi is
chef's kiss beautiful always love it
but it doesn't fit this story
logistically there's barely a reason for
them to communicate
with her at all again it has a
bit of a justification but there's no
reason it had to be her there's no way
and like oh there's no way they could
have found this out on their own well
you just said that in the script to
justify
having them talk to her but that's not
really true there were a million things
you could have done
to have them find out the same
information it's an excuse to have her
there
but the things that she needs to do in
order to establish
so that we can have stuff later i.e that
she's trying to be good that she could
escape
if she wanted but she's she's deciding
to stay there and she's
trying to work with the doctor on being
a better person these are all things we
need to know for the sake of
the rest of this series but
none of this benefits this story at all
and we are now
so far away from the really
well conceived depiction of
totalitarianism
that we had to open the episode we just
keep getting further and further and
further away from that
now we have unlike an action scene
assaulting
the monks base um i do
i do appreciate the detail again this
feels well thought out
in terms of these sorts of
um totalitarianism or fascist
governments um or people in charge
is that there aren't nearly as many as
they want you to think they have to
project
this idea of strength that is so
overpowering no one would dare threaten
them but the reality is they are nowhere
near as strong or as omnipresent
as they as people think they
are so again that's a really good
detail but you know we just get this
assault and one of the soldiers his
thing that's going
in his ear that is supposed to keep him
grounded
from the monks lies it goes awry and he
turns on them who the hell is this guy
nobody knows whoopty freaking do so
there's no tension in this scene
yeah it's not even like he was a
character that we met
and had gotten to know over the course
of just this episode he's just
a soldier character i think he
i think a name gets dropped who cares
who remembers
so there's time wasted on that there's
no catharsis there
there probably is a decently thought out
explanation
for why bill is able to
feed the idea of her mother and that
somehow regrounds the reality
and removes the monks from the
false history but i'm just i'm i zone
out
if there's an explanation by the time
they give it i i've kind of mentally
checked out of the episode
and i tried i tried to pay attention to
like
see if i could figure out the logistics
and i i can't say definitively whether
or not it makes sense because
i can't bring myself to focus on it
worth a day
my eyes and my brain just slide off it
by that point
because i'm just going you don't know
what you're doing anymore
you have gone from again really really
good
opening depiction of a totalitarian
fascist style
state to
the fake out regeneration
to a little bit of wackiness to the
interaction with missy
which doesn't flow naturally off of that
to the assault on the
monks which feels like a very
unearned as an action beat and now all
of a sudden
it's about the power of love and memory
channeled through bill's mom and like at
least they set up her mother a bit
you know her talking about her and you
know having this idea of her in her head
is something that was brought up earlier
in the series
we established the doctor uh helping her
get the pictures
you know that they did at least lay some
groundwork for the mother specifically
but that doesn't mean that it
fits any of the themes that have gone on
up to this point
it doesn't end with any of the themes
that it starts with and none of this
feels like it builds off
any of the themes from pyramid at the
end of the world
at least opening on the fascism and the
totalitarianism
stuff feels like oh we are dealing with
consequences of what happened before
but even that isn't necessarily a
natural progression from
the thematics of the previous episode so
the themes that are in here
are a jumbled mess that don't flow one
to the other where we end doesn't match
where we began
at all and i'm still not even entirely
clear
why the monks needed the planet in the
first place or wanted it
was it a want was it a need is this just
what they do is it a hobby
are they trying to collect them all
every inhabited planet in the
in the universe why why are they doing
this i get the how i get the how
they operate and the how is even
interesting
but why you know
at least with the daleks we know they
want to wipe everybody out even some but
something is as easy to write off as the
sycorax
they wanted slaves that's something
it's not a deep motivation but it's
something and these
monks that you have spent now three
episodes on
and have really given us an ominous
sense of their strength and the way they
use deception and
i think they're even decent villains
but i don't know why they want earth
and again maybe they even said it but
much like the specifics
of why the memory of bill's mother
saves the day my brain has decided
no i can't i can't with this by the
point that
it gets said if it gets said at all i
want to say it doesn't
but i it wouldn't surprise me if i get
comments saying oh they do explain why
the monks want earth it was this and
i'll just
and if that happens i'll look at the
comment and go
none of that registered at all
it is a shame because
the previous two entries in this
trilogy of episodes are really good
i mean extremists great even i would
argue
it's really a shame
lie of the land you've rewatched that
lately what'd you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down the comments let's talk
about the usual stuff like share
subscribe
i have a patreon that is how i pay my
bills and there are perks
things like discord early access to
videos voting on polls to help determine
um uh subjects look at my docket for
upcoming months and things like that
uh any amount you're able to give is a
help and gets you some degree of perks
but
um you also don't have to
i mean the other stuff i mentioned the
like share subscribers those helped me
out as well
but you don't even really have to do
that because at the end of the day
you are the council and i
just run the meetings until next time
this council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]